this is the Palace of the parliament
270 by 240 meters it is one of the
largest buildings on the planet and it's
probably the heaviest
however this concrete giant is small
compared with a master plan that created
it
in the late 1970s Romania's communist
leader decided he wanted something new
a socialist Capital that centralizes
country's political institutions and
cemented his reign
over the course of a decade Nikolai
chaucesku said in motion one of the most
destructive Master plans in human
history removing a section of Bucharest
as large as Venice
Romania is special located on the
Eastern end of the European continent
it's home to one of the most seismically
active areas in Europe the francian
mountain range within the carpathians
produces unusually strong earthquakes
and on March 4th 1977 Francia produced
an earthquake measuring more than seven
on the Richter scale
in Bucharest it killed more than 1 500
Romanians destroyed thousands of homes
and left tens of thousands homeless for
some Romanians it was one of the worst
disasters in their lives
but for one Romanian it was a blessing
in disguise
on the pretense of responding to the
destruction of the earthquake Nikolai
chaucesku announced that the country
needed to build a new capital in
Bucharest City Center
his plan was designed around three main
sections one the casa popaluri a massive
structure designed to hold Romania's
main political organs two a horizontal
axis of administrative buildings for the
bureaucrats and three a massive
Boulevard lined with luxury apartments
for the nomenclatura Romania's political
Elite
for his massive building chochesku
needed to scope out a safer location
some of Romania's communist political
institutions were damaged in the
earthquake and this couldn't happen
again
so we chose Arsenal Hill a mountain in
the center of Bucharest that provided
protection from earthquakes however
there was a problem because the hill was
safe it still had an entirely intact
neighborhood
actually this wouldn't be a problem for
chachesco at all he'd just destroy it it
was only a problem for the people living
there
in the mid to early 1970s Romania's
Communist Party adopted multiple
National systematization laws
the fundamental goal was to develop
backwards regions and prioritize dense
urban areas over rural ones
to do this the party ordered villages to
be converted into miniature cities with
Civic centers functional zoning and high
density buildings
at face value it didn't seem entirely
bad density can be good but Romania's
Communists were impatient
by the mid-1980s the party proposed that
thousands of villages in Romania had to
be entirely demolished and the
population relocated to different
villages in order to produce denser more
productive areas
fortunately for many this didn't end up
happening Romanians chose Revolution
over Central planning
but the individual neighborhoods in
Bucharest weren't as lucky
chachescu ordered the destruction of
more than ten thousand homes and
forcibly evicted more than fifty
thousand families
with a new blank canvas he could start
building
he launched a competition and received
multiple designs
a big fan of North Korea one of the
concepts he received looks like it came
straight out of Pyongyang made by the
20-something-year-old architect Anka
petresku she purposely built large paper
mache models to help convince ciao
chesku to choose her designs
and it worked although her North Korean
design wasn't chosen she proposed
another variation that did
considerably thinner than what we know
the building as today it still featured
its unique Four Corners
nonetheless it's hard not to notice how
different it still looks
see exactly what you'd expect from a
communistential planner chachescu was a
control freak who wasn't very easy to
please
he and his equally controlling wife
would visit the building's construction
site around three times a week they
wanted the columns to be Doric Ionic and
then dork again
windows that were round now needed to be
square he needed one more floor than
another one and then another one
he destroyed marble staircases ordered
them rebuilt ordered them destroyed
again and then ordered them rebuilt
again
it had no air conditioning specifically
because ciaochesku feared a poison
attack and he would order people to
measure flowers on decorating columns in
order to make sure that they were
symmetrical
over the course of the building's
construction it would take up around 30
percent of the entire country's budget
and overseeing the entire construction
and reconstruction was Anka the Chief
Architect
who underneath her had 700 other
individual Architects and thousands of
workers working in three shifts 24 7.
because ciao chesku was a man of the
Romanian people he ordered that the
entire building should be locally
sourced from Romanian materials
his Palace required around 1 million
cubic meters of marble 550 000 tons of
cement 700 000 Tons of Steel 2 million
tons of sand 900 000 cubic meters of
wood
3500 tons of Crystal 220
000 square meters of carpet and 3 500
square meters of leather
and his communist cronies created an
entire Crystal industry in Romania to
help build thousands of individual
chandeliers
while he organized the political
apparatus that scanned the streets to
catch and punish families who used more
than 140 watt light bulb his Palace was
rigged with tens of thousands
while he cut Central Heating and hot
water from Romanian households he
commanded the construction of a building
that today requires the same amount of
power as a mid-sized town
his building is made up of more than one
thousand individual rooms and has 14
floors 10 above ground and four beneath
building is also supposedly fitted with
an atomic bunker and a tunnel system
that could have secured an escape in
case of the need for an evacuation
unfortunately for Chuchu and his wife
their tunnels wouldn't be useful enough
in time
now that he had a design for his
building chuchesuku also needed an
equally Monumental access
called the victory of socialism
Boulevard it would purposely be made
longer than the chandelier
around 3.5 kilometers in length and 90
meters wide
lining is Boulevard are 10 story
apartment buildings that were intended
for key members of his party
from a distance his Boulevard seems like
it completely disregards the native
conditions of the city as though the
buildings were just glued on
and that's because they were
the kesku was a Romanian also known as
the engineer of Heaven
concerned about the planned communist
destruction he developed a system to
move churches and historical buildings
on Rails this allowed him and others to
save historical buildings that would
have otherwise stood in the way of
chachescu's grand plans
the last part of chachesco's plan were
the administrative buildings surrounding
the Piazza constitui a massive
semicircle where chachesco was supposed
to address his people
unfortunately for Nikolai though the
building would not be completed in time
for him to use it
instead Romanians grew restless and
they'd end chachu's reign
both him and his wife were sentenced to
death in a brief military show trial and
executed via firing squad
after his death chochesku's Palace
remained unfinished it was unclear what
to do with it there were those who
suggested that it should be demolished
it was the purest symbol of Communism
and chachescu's Cult of Personality
and there were also ideas to convert it
into the world's largest shopping mall
casino and even into a Dracula theme
park
it could have also been densified but
instead it was chosen to become the home
of Romania's government
today it houses both Romania's chamber
of deputies and the Senate
it is the biggest Parliament building on
the planet and the second largest
Administrative Building second only to
the Pentagon
the horizontal axis is still used by
Ministries and the square is now used
for concert venues
the boulevard is also still there of
course but instead of Apartments being
filled with members of the nomenclature
they are some of bucharest's most
valuable Apartments
[Music]
although chachesco's plans have now
become integrated and over time have
developed a practical political function
it should never be forgotten what this
building is
it is Europe's largest and youngest
symbol for centralized control and
authoritarian communism
constant reminder of how real it is to
be led by people who live and breathe do
as I say not as I do
this is your life in weeks if you're
lucky enough to turn 80 years old
each week a cube disappears taking away
a piece of your life that you'll never
get back
at first you may not care especially
when you have cubes to spare
but as you get older it becomes clearer
we know that our time binging TV shows
getting angry and regretful requires a
cost each Cube given is one that you'll
never get back
and there's probably no larger Cube
consumer than the job you choose to
dedicate your life to
eighty thousand hours is the amount of
time you'll spend in a career and it's
also the name of the non-profit that
wants to help you find a meaningful one
if your cubes have to go why not give
them to a career that impacts something
you care about
the choice of a career is a hard one but
80 000 hours is here to help you
they've been researching the question
for how you can find a fulfilling career
that also does good for years
they have a website that provides you
their research a podcast and also a
newsletter they have a job board that
provides hundreds of open listings for
potential high impact career paths and
all of their advice and research is free
forever
so if you're not sure what you should do
with your cubes or you're worried about
how you're spending them maybe check out
their in-depth career guide at eighty
thousand hours.org
remember life is short but what you do
with your decreasing time is up to you
foreign